hierbei zieht ihre bewegungen zum
gefechtsfeld aufgesessen sowie
abgesessen mit dem schützenpanzer land
der schützen bank zu land dient uns als
unterstützungs element das ist ein
wichtiges teil für uns panzergrenadiere
auf den wir uns verlassen muss
2012 als orf im einsatz im kosovo bei
einem vorgeschobenen checkpoint hatten
wir nur ein zelt zur verfügung das fast
120 mann dazu kommt 40 dementsprechend
weil dadurch die qualität des eng
zusammenrücken gefragt und das zeichnet
uns geredet hier aus
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ihr habt das gesehen was mensch und
maschine bedeutet wenn es so perfekt
harmoniert und so perfekt ineinander
greift wie bei eurer truppe das war
irrsinnig mehr eindruck und ein
wahnsinns tag bei euch und auch zu sehen
war es ja jederzeit bereit zu leisten ob
im inland und im ausland
das bringt eine wirklich große respekt
ab also danke nochmal gefährlich